[Music]
everybody in the skyboxes got the hint I
can see that very well that's great
will and everybody's back here and ready
for our second session this morning
because we have all very interesting
speakers to go and then we'll have QA
but Brown will have a panel discussion
here which I'll try to moderate and whip
people into shape and get some questions
from you from you all in the audience
our next speaker is Eric Kandel his lab
is studying examples of the major forms
of memory storage
dr. kandel is studying explicit memory
storage that's the conscious recall of
information about people places and
objects in mice an implicit memory
storage the unconscious recall of
perceptual and motor skills in the snail
that the sea snail he's so famous for I
remember going into his lab 25 years ago
at Columbia when I first starting out as
a reporter
and thinking you know this looks like my
aquarium back home like it's got only
snails around here I could good I
learned how much but she depends on
those snails by probing these synaptic
connections between nerve cells in the
sea slug dr. Kendall has uncovered some
of the basic molecular mechanisms
underlying learning and memory and
animals ranging from snails to flies to
mice and even in humans you're all
familiar with his work he has shared the
2000 Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine I'm sure he's going to be very
interesting talking about what he does
please welcome back to Eric Kandel
Thank You IRA for that introduction I
want to join my voices to that of the
other panelists and congratulate the
pick ours in Susumu for this wonderful
day in this wonderful dedication in this
magnificent building I want to discuss
with you some very personal thoughts
that I have about areas that I think are
likely to emerge as powerful issues and
brain sciences I'm picking areas that
are difficult and central to the field
but areas in which we have approached we
have the beginning to indicate some
directions in which you could move I
want to begin with the discussion of the
biology of conscious and unconscious
mental processes Richard already
indicated how they are important in
perception you also will hear from other
speakers how they're relevant for
thought and action and I want to
emphasize in particular the importance
of unconscious mental processes I then
want to use that as a stepping stone to
consider that we might very well expect
the revolution and understanding of
psychiatric disorders that I want to
begin by discussing the possibility of
having a biology of happiness not only
in the level of the individual but at
the level of the group and two of the
people who have contributed importantly
to group happiness or in the audience
Cori Bargmann at Tom Insel and finally I
want to return to the point that's
assumed who made and that is that brain
science is going to be an important
engine driving the future of knowledge
and that it's going to be I think an
important bridge between the humanities
the social sciences and the Natural
Sciences and I think it's wonderful in a
way that that Jim Watson is here because
simply to remind you was really with the
discovery of the structure of DNA by
Watson and Crick and the later
realization of the central dogma in
which sydney brenner was such an
important participant the biology became
unified molecular biology provided a
unification of the biological sciences
to which the Xoom
also contributed so biochemistry banker
genesis development immunology were
brought under a common intellectual
framework that was the task of the last
50 years in the next 50 years it is
going to be the opportunity for neural
science to provide that kind of a cement
that kind of a linkage between a number
of intellectual disciplines and
therefore it's appropriate that one
really restates the dogma if you will of
the 21st century that the 21st century
is going to be the problems of the mind
what the 20th century was to the
problems of the gene let me begin with
the first problem that of conscious and
unconscious perception one commonly
thinks of the fact that the idea of
unconscious came from Sigmund Freud but
it's only secondarily the first person
to really address himself to it in a
powerful way was Herman health's
Helmholtz an extraordinary physicist
turned neural scientists who carried out
a number of fantastic experiments he was
the first one to measure the speed of
conduction in axons an amazingly
accurate estimation and then he went on
to ask himself how long does it take for
reaction time to occur how long does it
take for somebody to consciously
perceive a visual object and he was
amazed with how long it took much longer
than it took for the information to get
into the nervous system and he stated
quite clearly that there must be a lot
of processing going on in the brain most
of which were unconscious about and of
course Richard so elegantly demonstrated
as the tubulin weasel that there is a
great deal of processing of sensory
information going on much of which were
unconscious about and there is in fact
sort of consensus now within the
scientific community that many of our
metal activities are carried out an
unconscious level but what is most
surprising is an experiment that Ben
lipid carried out much more recently in
which he pointed out that not only is a
lot of our mental activity unconscious
but even what we consider freewill is in
part determined in our conscious level
and they did this with the fantastically
interesting experiment
a German neurologist by the name of Korn
hooba had shown that if you initiate a
voluntary movement if you move your hand
or something like that you have a
readiness potential that you can detect
on the surface of the scalp and that
appears quite before the movement lipid
carried this one step forth forward he
asked people to will movements to
consciously weld movements and to note
exactly when they're willing occurs and
he was sure that this would occur before
the sign of the initiation of activity
before this readiness potential and what
he found was that it occurs
substantially after that so I could look
at your brain when you initiate a
voluntary movement and I can detect
electrophysiological II that you're
about to make a movement before you
yourself are aware that you're making
that movement that's an astonishing
result that suggested in some
sophisticated level there is an
unconscious decision to move prior to
you knowing that you've made that
decision so that was really raised the
question that to understand conscious
mentation you also need to understand
unconscious mental processes because so
much of mental activity is unconscious
and this is particularly interested to
psychiatrists who've been dealing with
sort of the dynamic of unconscious how
to tackle that an approach that Christof
Koch here has suggested together with
this work of Francis Crick is to take
situations in which one is flipping back
between conscious and unconscious States
and let me simply show you one common
way of doing this which is the figured
Brown delusion that is if you look at
this bars
you see Avaaz but the outlines of it and
either side also depict the face so you
can either see two faces or vars
depending upon what you're consciously
attending to it's an almost all or none
phenomenon you focus on one you don't
see the others if you focus on the
others you don't see the one this is an
interesting situation in which the mind
if you will that is the brain is
switching its
conscious attention from one object to
another it turns out when you do imaging
experiments while people are doing this
you find that when you're looking at the
vaz the area that is concerned with
object recognition lights up and when
you're looking at the faces the area
concerned with face recognition lights
up Richard pointed out to you all of
these things that topographically
organized the brain no surprise but what
is surprising is that conscious
perception it requires in addition the
participation of cortical areas in the
prefrontal region and in the parietal
region both those regions seem to be
involved in a number of different
conscious processes so it struck us as
seeing whether or not one could apply
this approach to emotion not just the
cognition and this is work
I mean Oetken carried out with joy
Hirsch at Columbia in which they exposed
normal subjects to a scary image if
threatening looking image and did it in
the two ways one a very brief exposure
in which the subject was not a way of
the fact that they were seeing a
frightening face and a more leisurely
exposure in which they could detect the
consciously the emotion and the image to
see what areas were involved they took
17 normal subjects and they decided that
emotion is likely to be different the
cognition in the sense that people's
sensitivity to threat might influence
their perceptual capability so they did
a basal anxiety test to Spielberg
inventory to get an estimate of basal
anxiety so they had that additional
information beyond the imaging let me
first show you the imaging data they
focused on the amygdala because they've
been known from other people's work that
this is important in the perception of
all emotional stimuli and they found
that when you expose subjects to a
conscious threat so they perceived it
and they could consciously tell you
about it a certain area the dorsal
amygdala lit up this is near the output
region of the amygdala but when the
subject unconsciously perceived a threat
the lateral nucleus lit up so two
different regions in the
make the light up depending upon whether
the threat is perceived as unconscious
or unconscious as conscious or
unconscious moreover this was associated
with different cortical networks this
with unconscious perception in this with
conscious perception the critical point
is that even there there's some overlap
only with conscious perception here as
in the earlier experiments the
prefrontal cortex and the parietal
cortex both together become active so
that suggests there may be some
commonalities to the conscious
perception of emotion as well as to the
concert
the conscious perception of cognitive
stimuli but the most interesting result
was that if you looked at the intensity
of the image in the two areas that lit
up with conscious and unconscious of
fear you saw that with conscious threat
independent of the baseline anxiety all
subjects lit up the amygdala just about
the same amount but inflicted
unconscious threat it varied a great
deal of depending upon the anxiety level
of the subject people who were very
relaxed the Richard axis of this world
no signal in the amygdala Rahl just
wasn't there people who are extremely
anxious a very dramatic signal why is
that interesting it's really interesting
from two points of view first of all it
tells you that the unconscious
perception is extremely important to
people's actions one one way of thinking
about this is once you see a face once
you have the leisure to really perceive
it clearly what it is it isn't a threat
it's just a picture looking at you but
if you see a partial view if you
unconsciously perceive it so you'd not
sure what's there then you can allow
your imagination to wander and people
anxious gonna think this is terrible
people are secure gonna give a damn
about it
so it gives you some idea of how the
mind is working if you will but even
more interestingly I think one of the
important things that we're going to
need in the long run are markers for
different mental illnesses so we can use
imaging as a way of evaluating the
outcome of therapy and you can see that
as Delta perhaps cognitive behavioral
therapy are some kind of a
scientifically valid a
form of psychotherapy one might be able
to take people that have a very large
signal threat and bring it down to this
particular point as a result of the
therapeutic experience so what I'm
suggesting is that one might be able to
open up an approach to psychotherapy
using this these kinds of imaging
methods but that takes one to the larger
issue and I'm sure Tom will talk about
this and that is we've had an enormous
explosion of progress in neurology as a
result of molecular biology in contrast
we have not seen comparable developments
in psychiatry and I fully expect the
next 20 to 30 years we're going to see
this one of the reasons has been so is
because there have been problems in in
psychiatry we know very little about the
Nano Tomica substrates and most mental
illnesses we know very little about the
genes that are involved except we know
that the genetics is complex as a result
of this we haven't been identified we
haven't been able to identify many of
the specific genes involved and as a
result we haven't been able to do what
people have been able to do in Neurology
with Huntington's disease in various
important genes in neurologic diseases
put them into experimental animals and
try to delineate the mechanisms of
pathogenesis I'd like to suggest that
this is beginning to be possible that we
are beginning to learn about anatomical
substrates of a number of diseases that
we're beginning to identify certain
genes I'd like to give you some insight
into mechanisms of pathogenesis just a
little tidbit if you will and like to
focus on the most complex of all
psychiatric disorders schizophrenia as
most of you know schizophrenia has three
types of symptoms the positive symptoms
which is really the major evident aspect
of the disorder when the disease
presents disorder thought hallucinations
and delusions these are difficult to
model on the mice how would you know
whether Mouse is deluded or whether a
mouse is hallucinating
when these pasts you're left with two
very bothersome residual symptoms social
withdrawal and blunted affect would have
called the negative symptoms that is the
lack of social interaction
disordered life attentional deficits
deficits in working memory we know that
a lot of this involves the prefrontal
cortex the area that Earl Miller works
in and we know from Pat Coleman
Marquesas work that this is in fact and
other people's work that this is a
region that is defective in
schizophrenia so Elinor Simpson in my
lab and Christophe calendar have thought
that they would try to model cognitive
symptoms of schizophrenia in the mouse
using one fairly reliable genetic
finding many patients with schizophrenia
show an increased expression of d2
receptors in the striatum so they
engineered a mouse that expresses the d2
receptor only in this writer and they
expressed it in a way that allowed them
to turn the gene on and off when they
turned the gene on only in the stratum
they showed a very characteristic
working memory deficit in a number of
different tasks
now one of the interesting things about
this one knows from treatments of
patients with schizophrenia that if you
give drugs that work in this disorder
and most of these are dopamine d2
receptor blockers the same gene that's
being expressed here it's just about the
same level that you see it in patients
with schizophrenia that those drugs do
not help the cognitive symptoms and they
don't help the negative symptoms
significantly they primarily work on the
loosen ations in the delusions so here
we could see you know what's going on we
can turn this gene off and see whether
or not the cognitive deficit disappears
and we find that when return the gene
off just like giving drugs the cognitive
deficits persist suggesting some
secondary change has occurred we've now
shown that in the prefrontal cortex d1
receptor expression is decreased and Pat
Coleman rakeesha shown that this causes
a severe impairment in working memory so
I'm only indicating that one can begin
to use mice to work out mechanisms of
pathogenesis and I think this is going
to prove very productive in the future
I've described to you that we know
beginning to know something about the
amygdala and its role in fear well what
about happiness security what is the
nature
of happiness where did biological
underpinnings now there's an important
clue that came from Tolstoy's Anna
Karenina in which he pointed out that
happy families are all alike every
unhappy family is unhappy in its own way
so this suggests probably not true that
there are universal mechanisms that
you're likely to delineate when you come
to happiness and I have some personal
experience to think that this is so here
are two people for example who are happy
so Zhu mu is happy because he's wearing
my tie and I'm happy because I'm
attending this marvelous opening and
notice the similarities not only they're
both happy but we've now used some of
Sydney Brenda's essays on Sassoon when
we found that there are a few genes in
his genome that are Jewish genes and he
used the same essay and mean it's
absolutely clear that I have a Japanese
background so there there are obvious
commonalities my Grogan in my lab was so
impressed with that picture that he
decided to do the following experiment
for years people had studied learned
fear which is very easy to produce in
the mouse what you do is you take a
neutral tone boom and you're paired with
a shock that scares the hell out of a
mouse and you go tone shocked tone
shocked and after a while the animal
gets frightened just at the tone and
this simply shows you what these
experiments are like if you give an
animal a tone the animal this is just a
normal animal walks around like a normal
Mouse and that is it walks on the
outside of this box occasionally making
darting movements inside to make sure
that it's not missing anything
interesting but most of the time it
wants to protect itself it works in the
outside if you look at the response in
the loop a lateral nucleus of the
amygdala that's the nucleus that's
involved in the perception of fear you
see that the tone produces a small
signal if you now scare the animal so
the animal responds to that same tone
with fear it now stays in one corner of
that enclosure that open field and it
just freezes there and if you look at
the signal you see its dramatically
enhanced but if you teach the animal
safety if you teach the animal
that whenever the tone comes on it'll
never get shocked it gets shocked at
other times but never when the tone
comes on it realizes that the only time
it can really enjoy itself is when the
tone comes on then under these
circumstances it walks around like
Susumu tonegawa in the pic hour as if it
owns the place
and if you look at in the lateral
nucleus you see that this signal is
depressed so this is very interesting
but you could say well maybe what you're
just doing is reducing a certain level
of baseline anxiety is this true
happiness are you lighting up the
systems of the brain that make you
genuinely happy these the areas of the
brain that light up when you take drugs
that make you feel very good and the
areas that light up at the striatum and
Mike Brogan was interested in knowing
does the striatum light up with learned
safety is the actual joy in this is the
actual happiness and he found that
indeed there was when he recorded the
signal to safety in the dorsal striatum
he found there was an increase in
response to the tone in in the striatum
while the danger signal had no effect
whatsoever when the animal expressed
learned fear there was no change
whatsoever this is the opposite of where
I showed you before with danger in the
lateral amygdala the signal gets larger
and with safety the signal gets smaller
so you see that in fact one can begin to
open up a biology of happiness and
clearly these pathways that are
recruited by various kinds of
reinforcing stimuli seem to be
positively seem to be involved in that
but I would suggest that perhaps an even
more profound area which the new biology
of mine is gonna open up for us is the
area that Cori Bargmann and Tom Insel
have pioneered in' and that's the
understanding of social behavior Tom
will probably return to this and let me
just give you two very simple examples
quarry in a very beautiful study showed
that there are different strains of
worms C elegans worms that that forage
for food in different ways some are
loners they like to go at it by
themselves and they sort of crawl around
get bacteria which is the source of
their food
by just going as individuals others do
it collectively feasts group
get-togethers and she analyzed the
difference between them and she found
that was due to a receptor to a
particular neuropeptide and as she
pointed out neuropeptides are regulators
of lots of behavior and she showed one
amino acid difference in this peptide
receptor a receptor for inner peptide
similar to neuropeptide Y determined
whether or not the worm moves as a
solitary individual or as a social
organization well that's an extremely
profound insight they one can change the
social behavior of organisms by really
authoring a single gene and Tom Insel
explored this and even if you will a
more dramatic and and we are relevant to
our own life situation with two
different species of voles these are
rodent like animals the prairie voles
are highly social animals they're
constantly throwing parties getting
together taking off their clothes and
dancing on the table but they're very
loyal to one another they pair bond and
they stick together all the time so this
is does not reflect what happens
typically in the neuroscience community
the neuroscience community is more
promiscuous somewhat a social they move
around more like the Montaigne voles
there's a single individuals again tom
has found that this is due to an
alteration in a single gene that encodes
a peptide a receptor to vasopressin and
he's shown that the promoter region the
region regulates it is different in
these two species and that promoter
determines the exact level of expression
of the gene in various regions as which
it's expressed in fact he's been able to
take mice that behave like this and put
a social gene into it and get them to
become more social I think this is
really quite remarkable when you think
about because but you're looking at
social behavior you also will get some
insight in the biology of group behavior
and group behavior is not all positive
there is a tendency we've seen in or
groups including our own to defend our
own territory and fight everybody else
so aggression come
out of group behavior so we might be
able to get some insight into the
biology of aggressive behavior as well
and finally I want to indicate as Zuma
did that I think for a university such
as MIT one of the most amazing things
that's going to come out of brain
science is how it's gonna affect other
areas of knowledge and I'm just gonna
sort of list sort of obvious examples
you yourself will be able to think of
them just to continue the theme I had
before a molecular biology of a social
behavior is going to be important for
several reasons
sociology academic sociology is in a
funk at the moment it is not coming up
with new ideas it is in a holding
operation and I think an infusion of
biological thought into social behavior
is going to have a tremendous stimulus
to the group to to sociology and I think
it allow us to get us things like
empathy and aggression and promiscuity
and pair-bonding and interesting issues
like that I showed you before how the
biology of free will this is an
interesting issue if you're not aware
consciously of your actions are you
legally responsible for actions you can
have telematic arguments that can go on
for three times the length of the
symposium and that one issue alone the
nature of person's responsibility these
are important legal questions and just
like DNA fingerprinting has been so
informative and useful to the law my
guess is that we will use brain biology
in a similar way you'll hear this
probably more from Pat Churchland but
all the issues we're talking about my
ability to image your brain and know
before you know what you're gonna do
raises lots of ethical issues that need
to be considered the whole nature of
appreciation is likely to undergo a
radical change
understanding how sensory systems and
Richard gave you some beautiful examples
of that process information is alone one
aspect of it and even deeper one is the
aesthetic response
you know why do two people look at the
same object and one finds that beautiful
the other finds it boring what is the
nature of the response and conceivably
we could get some handle on the basis of
creativity as well neurobiology is
beginning to interact actively with
economics and with business schools
because there is a biology opening up of
decision and choice Bill Newsom for
example it's been interesting these
problems are all really a group of
people that actually using economic
models and applying it the
neurobiological context in order to
understand the rules that govern the
biology of decision-making and people in
economics interested in seeing what the
outcome of those results are and finally
I should say that there is a
disappearance of conventional sciences I
think it's fair to say that psychology
insofar as it concerns itself with human
psychology the psychology of higher
mental processes is now can't be
distinguished from neuroscience they're
isomorphic and there's a point that part
of course made and it applies absolutely
as she has documented the philosophy of
mind you can't do philosophy of mind
unless you understand the neuroscience
that she understands and if you look at
the good philosophers of mind as Pat or
John Searles they are essentially
neurobiologist they they have the
intellectual background moreover I think
that's going to be a tremendous impact
within medicine we've so far been
training neurologists and psychiatrists
that they're two species apart even
though they're looking at the same organ
this is not to say that it takes a
different character structure to work
with patients that have mental illness
then it works with neurological diseases
but this is a little bit like being a
kidney specialist than being a heart
specialist you have to start off an
internal medicine you need a common base
and I think Tom and I share the same
sentiment that it would be important to
change the whole pedagogy of neurology
and psychiatry but beginning with the
common training that both disciplines at
the very beginning of that experience so
that both of them realized they're
looking at different aspects of brain
functions and this brings me to the the
romantic component in my Viennese
character structure and that is that I
still have hope so psychoanalysis
no I'm probably the only one in this
room I know Jim feels very strongly
about this and he may very well be right
at the point I'm not doing is selling
you an analysis but to say that for the
first time we're in a position to
evaluate the efficacy of these
psychotherapeutic procedures and we can
see whether or not they work or whether
or not they they don't work and I think
if you willed this biology offers a hope
to these therapeutic approaches in order
to see whether or not they can be put on
the scientific basis as a result of this
so I'd like to simply conclude by saying
that the impact of neuroscience in the
future of knowledge the future of the
university is enormous
I think there's practically no area of
knowledge that is not going to be
impacted by it and I think the pit cow
is going to be in a great position to
lead that charge thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
Tom Cruise just called he's working on a
new movie well he knows what you're
gonna do in advance remember that movie
he arrested people who are gonna commit
murder before good so they knew what
they were gonna do now he's got some
backing for another movie we'll talk
about that later there in the panel
discussion let's be very interesting
another interesting gentleman our last
Nobel Prize well how do you introduce
James Watson he really needs no
introduction everybody knows who he is
he if formally is Chancellor of Cold
Spring Harbor Laboratory but his most
famous of course as the research partner
of Francis Crick a little over 50 years
ago
Watson and Crick unraveled the shape of
DNA discovered that it was a double
helix and dr. Watson remains an active
scientist author and lecturer and he
says he says in his own biography my
long-term interest in education is most
tangibly demonstrated by my helping
generate three widely used textbooks
molecular biology of the gene molecular
biology of the cell and recombinant DNA
please welcome dr. James Watson
well I'll be unlike the other speakers
and won't congratulate the peak hours
I'm going to congressional aide MIT
because you know MIT is managed you know
to get to with a gigantic donors to
neuroscience and these donors being very
intelligent advise people you know it
didn't want to waste their money and so
the chose MIT so I think we really
should congratulate the vision of MIT as
expressed in its long history and in its
past president Charles West and its
current presence su hak felt for really
providing you know have momentum which
sort of scares the out of those who
don't have the resources of MIT or the
pic hours of the government so you know
so I'm asked to you know sort of predict
where the future is and so I'm trying to
you know how can we with much that's
coast recover with much less money be as
important as their mighty you know just
a compete and you know be is good and
you know I think the answer is you know
you have to know a lot and really going
and so I'll start by saying you know
maybe it was six months before Francis
Crick I'd I wouldn't saw and he said
because he'd spent 25 years thinking
about the brain and it's particularly
consciousness and said we hadn't found
the double helix of the brain that is
you don't know how to think about it and
so we well what it would be the double
helix and yeah they're just to really
just gigantic problems which haven't
been really mentioned here at all well
one is just how is perceptual
information stored what does it look
like you know when we saw the double
helix we saw it was just the secret
sebassis but we don't have any idea how
the information in this story the second
is and maybe this isn't a real problem
how is this information pushed from one
part of the brain to that doesn't really
go from the hippocampus to the
prefrontal cortex I mean how can you do
it I mean it just seems totally you know
that you need you know no designer could
be intelligent to really move it from
one part of the brain so you know I
really worry about but maybe you know
this problem will disappear the moment
we know what restoring but in any case
we have to know what restoring then then
and again thinking about the double
helix the double here was made possible
because chemists had come along before
and essentially gave the circuitry of
you know how the sugar was like the
phosphate so we had a two dimensional
chemistry and then we could put it in
three dimensions and I'm sort of struck
there has been much real mention of
Anatomy it maybe she just sounds too
boring for an institution as
my power does MIT but I think you got to
do a lot of it here will you've got to
know the circuits that I was very struck
by we had a meeting and coachmen
hardware gavin urging systems and the
work of in Lausanne or markup in this
group you know he was really trying yes
the anatomy of a micro collar I mean a
cortical call and I think we just have
to do this now and the question is do
you want to do it on the mouse or
wouldn't it really be better to just do
it everything on the south side and I
think it's really open that is whether
the mouse despite all the things you can
do with it is just too complicated ever
to see the information now the only one
who's seen the information is Eric you
know the synapse got thicker but that's
one synapse so how are you going to go
along and see just what's happening and
I think the winner will be someone who
chooses the right system you know not
necessarily the one with the most money
so it's not clear that this building
will be where the great discovery we
make
and so that's where the real soft will
be and then and what else is really
missing here
well you're not biologists you're
molecular biologists you know that's
sort of the basis of it and there was
one word of mention about evolution here
you know how did the brain develop what
did it have to do and you know it's not
surprising the striatum does something
first it's an old part of the brain and
the prefrontal cortexes last so you sort
of think would go in that direction so
there really seemed to be no one's
really thinking of how the brain
developed in this different place now
this was sort of speculation you know 75
years ago then people were more
evolutionary and orang2 than they are
now but I think you sort of totally
forgot it and we had a course this past
summer I coach we cover in schizophrenia
and John listen came from Brandeis and
he was certain to do the systems but
what it just proved is that a you know a
bright physicist can only think about
three things so the brain is more than
three things it's an awful lot of things
all working together and you got a gnome
all and almost none of the conversation
really tries to link them all in terms
of evolutionary histories where did the
hippocampus come you know just how did
the think the whole system evolved so
you know I just think you ought to get
someone who knows evolution just my
guess I mean you go out and do nice work
but I don't think you'll do anything
profound despite all your money because
maybe you quite haven't asked how the
whole thing came together all right I
hope that's true because we're gonna
think evolutionary we don't have any
money and so
so we'll see what we can do okay then
the last thing and I was so scared you
know what here we talk because I've read
his autobiography and he's so many
things that he'd actually say what I'm
gonna say was thank God he didn't and so
it is basically you know mental disease
of various forms and the effort we
should play store trying to find the
genetic basis so it and this isn't a
function of this building you've got the
broad and Erica's got just another 100
million dollars so he should get
somewhere but I'm not sure he will
because we think about what
schizophrenia is you know and so I think
about it an awful lot for a very tragic
reason I have a son with schizophrenia
and you know for the most part you know
the psychiatrists aren't up to it that's
all and that's not to say they're stupid
but you know some of them aren't very
bright I'll tell you laughing you see
this when your children are with them
okay you know
and so so right now we sort of have this
dichotomy in the bipolar disease and
schizophrenia and my son you know they
couldn't tell me what he had and finally
they ended up he had a pervasive
developmental disability not otherwise
specified we don't know anything now
people have you know tried to separate
these things through the two categories
bipolar schizophrenia and they've done
the genetics tried to do the genetics
it's the general impression that is fail
it's not true it's given some really
important most important is that both
diseases he you end up with that
completely overlap piece intervenes but
a lot of them are just the same so what
does that mean is that there's something
really in common and so it stopped so
the disease is in really two things one
that is schizophrenia and who's first
described is that learning a thought
disorder people can't think a very
disorganized thought and it goes we're
more than just your prefrontal you can't
move their body right you're not going
to ever be a great picture or anything
like that
the whole brain really just can't learn
and that's why and then the second part
of the disease is or it looks like in
what's studied by these genes is sort of
going into psychosis where you end up
with the you know the cause of all your
dilemmas is not the genes with cie which
is you know listening in and providing a
reason for it right so what does the
this common genetics well there's the
disk disrupted with schizophrenia on
chromosome one found out of bed
and then there's from some can I think
it's ten there's nitric oxide nitric
acid and nos okay and what are those
things have in common they're published
signals for neurogenesis so the
underlying defect may be that the and
people when they look at the hippocampus
in schizophrenia just seem small and if
you asked about what what's what's
missing
it's the granule cells it's a
neurogenesis so there's a you know
whether all learning has to involve new
cells you know in the striatum or
something probably not but you know what
really is happening when you learn a
sort of awful fact we heard of course
was that if your child walked six weeks
six months later they're like average he
has a three times greater risk for
schizophrenia it just me says something
the learning is slowed down much more
difficult they can't learn faces all
these things why don't they want to be
with people it's hard for them to learn
the face you know it's not a lot of but
it's a very deep learning defect so if I
can give you any advice publish your
path and I don't want to give it to you
because that's what we're gonna do is
that probably your Institute will move
really fast if it's friends half-assed
effort on schizophrenia and bipolar
disease because it's really a learning
defect that's what you say you're
learning I mean if that's your objective
and
so it wouldn't be surprising you know
with the finding I guess which cream out
of PMS first these extraordinary finding
that you know antidepressants work by
promoting neurogenesis I mean that's
really important and so if you know we
that were finding these several genes
involved in DNA replication which he
says producing new cells is awfully
important awfully important and I think
so what you want to do is how you
produce new cells you know is there some
way you can do it now for those of us
you know who's sort of think we're
normal and the chief problem which
should be affecting everyone in this
room is that at least downstairs
everyone seems to be you know over
thirty and that means you're way past
your prime and being able to learn and
if we're like mice the neurogenesis is
steadily was slowing down and so is
there any way we can actually with
adults speed up neurogenesis and
probably you know raise the IQ you know
because your IQ goes down it's all you
know the psychologists don't like to
tell you these sort of things you have
to realize age but so you know whether
my playing tennis you know is it general
stimulant for neurogenesis or is it only
doing something to the striatum I don't
know and you know is reading a book
actually in some sense creating a signal
which leads to neurogenesis I hope so
certainly they say the hippocampus are
that
there's Warren or Genesis and London cab
drivers they really have to remember
that so I think it's you know both very
important is pure science and it's very
very important practical we need to get
noir Genesis and if I had been arranged
as a prozium I would have had Pat gave
the same because I think he is important
and that the sort of concluded is I've
been trying to think of an evolutionary
reason why we lose the ability to learn
as we get older and I think the reason
must be that actually the brain is
pretty finite and you can only have so
much stored and to put new things in you
got to get rid of old things
and the past we wanted to retain the
past in the brain we evolved to retain
the past because we had no books or maps
so old people were actually useful you
know they knew they they had crossed the
mountain knew where you know the rivers
went and where there was water but now
you can just look it up in the map I
mean you don't have you don't need old
people at all you know the big message
for Japan you can say well this is an
unpleasant fact okay so we won't accept
it but what we have to learn is that we
have to accept the truth that comes out
of biology and it may not be pleasant
but that you know sometimes we can do
something about so you know instead of
spending money for more teachers in New
York City system maybe we should
spending the money how to increase
neurogenesis same effect I don't know
but I do think
the genetics of schizophrenia is really
telling you something very important and
that the next couple years are going to
be very exciting
thank you
thank you dr. Watson I'd like to invite
all our panelists to come up to the
stage because we'll start talking about
what you've heard today
I know I've written like a dozen two
dozen questions that I wanted to ask and
I have to I think I have to rip them all
up now because there's so much more
interesting things that I had heard and
I'll also invite people from the
audience we have a couple of microphones
down here to take questions if you sort
of stand up and be recognized or former
a little line in the aisle there
I am also informed by the architects who
truly love the acoustics which like I do
the building they said you can get
questions from up there and then in this
seats also or and I'd be happy if you
want to shout down a question if you
have one to take a question from up
there and I'll repeat the question if if
people can't hear you so I like to
strike something different but and in
starting off the discussion and ask any
of our panelists if they heard something
I'd like to ask of the on someone else
about on the panel here's something
provocative or something you'd like to
know more about make believe we're
sitting in your coffee klatch did you
hear something you need to know more
about how about I'd like to ll me let me
just bring an overall theme that I that
I detected that I thought I would detect
when we talked we talked about research
and that's the it seems the
nature-nurture question I mean we've all
just talking about brain chemistry and
biology here is there no nature involved
in shaping any of these things any of
these behaviors and influences that
become permanent part and how important
is to study that let me just say it more
I see the people looking at me like I'm
crazy which I might be you're talking
you talked about the influence of DNA
and the genes on the structure of the
brain where does nature come in that
effects that behavior how much as how
much does that change the plasticity of
what's going on there dr. candle yeah
maybe I would begin I think you are
using the terms in somewhat different
ways yes we refer to nurture
as being the thing that the environment
gives you in nature is that right right
I think one of the sort of significant
insights that come along is that nurture
works through nature that is
environmental contingencies learning new
experiences effect alterations of gene
expression in the brain and can lead the
anatomical changes so although these are
not heritage you have changes in gene
expression that lead to growth in the
brain as result of it various
environmental impact and you yes dr. axe
I think it's important I'll make an
extreme statement and that is the the
nervous system of all organisms is
hardwired and that hardwiring is
dictated by genes that hardwired nervous
system has evolved to accommodate the
particular evolutionary needs of an
individual species so your nervous
system is innately determined and that
innately determined set of connections
then forms the substrate upon which
experience can shape the way you
perceive the world so you have to
remember the innately determined
structure with which we are all
individuals are endowed anybody gonna go
you saw it you know when we study the
mutants the behavior of a mutants
basically what we are doing is trying to
understand the limit of a nature in
other words we have a genes which give
us a framework of what this machine can
do right and within that framework this
machine happened to be the one which
interact it is made in such in such a
way that interact with the environment
we can incorporate information into it
and in fact it's all
it even alters the hardwiring so that in
the nature-nurture relationship that's
the way I look at so the memory learning
in the nurture as we know and but you
can't do learn something beyond the
limitation of the nature we have I mean
you can't run the hundred meter dash to
be the one second even if you want to
however practice you do it you don't do
that check the what did you want to
smell someone asked me to write a
preface to a book uh nature nurture so
I've been just reading the articles and
and one was just on the influence of
smoking pot your chance to coming down
with schizophrenia and it really seems
to be a really nasty every it's a real
cause if you take it in adolescence
we're not in adults so I think the brain
isn't really totally wired in
adolescence and there's really rather
fragile and we probably you know have to
be much more firm to our children really
the harm they can do someone last night
was telling me again that alcohol taken
really early in life really can lead to
much greater chance of becoming an
alcoholic then if you start drinking
alcohol at MIT it's alright but it we
start drinking it in high school is
really bad for you know you know whether
that's a solid fact or not it's a very
important fact that we should has
enormous consequences as to you know the
England which is the decline they've
eaten and they just drinking drinking
drink in adolescence Jim points out a
very important issue that is commonly
phrased in terms of critical periods is
you've extended that but one can show
for example that certain kinds of
insults like closing a lid which would
have no effect than you and me as adults
has catastrophic effects
on kittens visions for example if you
close the eye for a certain even
relatively brief period of time a few
days you can alter the ability for that
eye to be able to handle visual
information later on and this is a
cortical damage this is not a damage in
the retina and for various kinds of
things for example parenting there are
experiments not only in in primates but
also in people in which you show that if
kids are deprived of appropriate
paternal and maternal care that has bad
consequences of their ultimately
maturing so there are for many aspects
of karri development critical periods in
which the environment has to be
supportive in an appropriate way in
order to for the brain to develop
normally
thanks tonic are you talking you want to
propose in relation to this critical
period issue and the nature not
generation there are at least two real
water the expert in the audience
Michael striker and Mark Baer are they
are they here right so mark what what do
you have something to say about that
well thank you well what I have to say
about that is is that I think that the
work that we have done suggests that
it's far worse to have a bad experience
than no experience at all so this term
deprivation has to be really defined so
for example closing an eyelid is not the
absence of light but it's replacing the
normal patterns of retinal activity that
we use for vision with uncorrelated or
noisy or static activity and it's really
that bad activity that causes the
problem it's not the absence of activity
so it's better to have no experience at
all than a bad experience from that
point of view let me ask you to dr.
tonegawa you were talking about the
hardware inventing hardware that you
don't know what it's gonna be yet
right what do you want to measure with
the hardware how do you know what to
invent what would you like to measure
with the hardware so that you could
invent the hardware
I said I'll ask that off to all of you
what what's the machine that you need to
understand this machine that you have
well yeah Jim pointed out that we need
we need to know much more about their
Anatomy right and this is what they're
Francis Crick always told when he was
healthy and I think this is very true
that we should know more about the you
know the basic anatomy of the brain and
this is a very difficult thing to
convince young people because it first
of all is it difficult to be funded that
kind of research but I think it's very
important to really establish the basis
over which we study the interaction with
with the environment and I think very
rid of it now for instance people talk
about this function of prefrontal cortex
you know delay cells for working
memories and so on but the people don't
know what cells which kind of cells how
many different kind of cells are
composing the prefrontal cortex yeah I
was very surprised when I remember who
showed this slide of the synapse that we
don't know what this and this and this
is on the synapse yep it was very
interesting that we late people think
that you know everything about nerve
cells and all the parts and obviously
there's still a lot to be studying even
a basic part the working parts I guess
well guess what my point was do you know
what I mean we talk about MRIs extra all
kinds of scanners do you have an idea
what the scanner is that neat what you
have to look at so that you know how to
design a new kind of scanner what is the
part that you try yeah yeah sure well
thats camera we have now is not
measuring the real activity of neurons
it is measuring the metabolism activity
of metabolism right so we need to know
the real property of the cell which is
the change in the electric potential
across the neuronal cell membranes and
one should write to know this one would
read to notice at the very high
resolution so if a single cell you know
have the thousand thousands of synapses
I mean the different part of the cell
has a different level of a potential
depending on how the stimulus went
through that cell and that's what we
should know we want to know the property
delayed property of the cell which is
electrically expressed because of the
ion pass-through passing through the
membrane dr. Watson did you dr. brenner
did you want to say just on the synapse
I think that's grants and Cambridge is
trying to do proteomics um and it's
about 800 proteins that's probably an
underestimate so there will be many many
different mutations by which you can
become stupid so it's you know you'll
find a few that will stand out like
fragile X and so on but you're probably
just gonna find it and that's probably
behind a lot of the difficulty of doing
schizophrenia genetics particularly what
you're worried about this defects there
are present at the age two or something
there's so many different ways in order
not to be functional when you said
before that we haven't found the double
helix of the brain yet do you think
there's some underlying mechanism that
will take a paradigm shift for us to
suddenly see all the cortex looks the
same information is likely stored in the
same way and
[Music]
I think we're gonna find it out but you
know it's not clear you know what system
we can look at to see it and that's
where ingenuity will come from you know
choosing the right organism to do it you
know every quit you know be nice if you
can do it was appreciate you know that
you did get the big general principle
out of it but I don't know there I've
been one point the the Jim made which I
think is a very good one and that is
comparative analyses in the 1950s many
people in neural science for developing
new model systems and in part because of
the success of certain systems and in
part because of funding it's extremely
difficult to develop new systems in
neurobiology and that has been a great
impediment to the development of a
comparative approach but I must say that
the sort of the neuroanatomical studies
that have becoming out of the bird brain
have been a very illuminating so there
is some work going on but I agree that
it's not enough if you have a question
just wait for yes up there sir
dr. brenner did you hear that he wants
to know these questions about the
ethical challenges facing neurological
research and drugs that might come out
to change neurology well III think we've
got a terrific method of changing the
brain you just have to talk to people so
I think there's a big conception in
people's mind between being a person and
being just a product of a genome a
person is much more than just the body
and all the other stuffs there because
when people talk about cloning people
and so on they usually think of it as
someone once asked me at a lecture why
can't I clone myself and keep the copies
for spare parts my reply was be careful
one of the copies might keep you for
spare parts he didn't consider the
copies as persons there were just things
you hung them up in a cupboard you
needed a new finger you cut it also
glued a Tong see so there's and when
people talk unit we have remarkable
social ways of claiming people they
called armies they called schools we we
are cloning persons they were trying to
make everybody with identical behavior
so the clue is for people as I said at
the beginning I think just forget about
biological evolution whether spontaneous
or engineered we can change the
phenotype of people very clearly and
just to go back to one of the earlier
questions the nature-nurture one see as
you go down in the scale where you have
like a little finite nervous system we
have the whole wiring diagram done most
of the behavior is hardwired
most of the behavior is hardwired
that is this organism's genome and what
it does in its life is effectively
predetermined very accurately
predetermine then you can see as you
ascend the evolutionary scale actually I
think the nematode is going downhill
basically I think it's had its day it's
a degenerate animal it's not the
primitive animal
it's degenerate anyway that's another
time just let me say finally that the
other thing that struck me is that even
in flies it's hard to discover whether a
single animal learns the learning is
statistical because what's the aim of
the learning it's to saves the species
it's not to save you or me well that
seems to be one of the things we're
talking about is it how does the fact
actually and as we go up the scale once
we come to people I think we've got a
completely think we have this wonderful
invention you take this hardwired
nervous system you know which
essentially specifies the end location
of the EDA's in the hypothalamus
basically the center of greed lust
avarice and desire that's why it's
called the GLAAD project for happiness
so and we've grafted onto this onto this
basic mechanism something which learns
when I think could we encode all of
human products in DNA I mean if I were
the intelligent designer I mean that
would be the stupid design that we try
to write in genes you know everything
that we can do it wouldn't work what you
do is you produce this thing and by
interacting with the environment you can
generate you
varieties of behavior that's the beauty
of the nervous system you wouldn't want
to hard-code it you take something which
is hardwired because it has to be built
and then you have this wonderful
flexibility now I forget what you are
one no the ethical things we should also
talk about the ethics of of trying to
make people uniform I think that's much
more that's much more things that we
have to think about good dr. Watson yes
do you think you're any part of your
uniqueness has been due to your
environment
no okay so when you really look at
unique people they don't seem to arise
out of their environment now I think
someone else how do you account for
yourself I say I had good genes that's
it I have good doctors good for my drink
single malt I think it didn't matter
where you were born or where you grew up
into what's family now I mean it doesn't
make sense to say whether you you're the
product of both you're the product of
that's not what you said you say they
were just your genes that's what we have
to tell them which one is the Joginder
which one
we take you very seriously here that for
example I've got to everybody knows
there is a gene on the Y chromosome for
reading in the toilet that's not they
that's not the chromosome we males are
all losing factor X let me just drill
down and fab a question question out
here and leak go there and I'll go to my
question yes hi this is a question for
all of the panelists of dr. axel you
mentioned how genes help lay the
foundation for hardwired circuits but we
know that the brain changes and is
modifiable by experience so my question
to you all is as you advise those of us
were beginning our studies in the field
what are the foundations with which we
should now use to study the rules of
plasticity of how these hardwired
circuits change in adulthood should we
still study genes do the answers still
lie in the genes or should we move on to
looking at protein pathways or cortical
network changes or or some combination
of these fields pathways that they
express themselves are great should we
should you waste your time with anything
but the genes is what you said it's
clear that these genes have the genetic
studies have told us a lot about how
hard wired circuits functioning so my
question is um as we move on to studying
brain plasticity neuroscience in the
next decade are we still do you think
genes still hold answers for us search
for these genes behind mental disease if
they give you enormous clothes but if
you're just a gene jock and you've been
trained to do it just go work in
industry you don't belong here out for a
while I mean you know it's not enough
you know just to manipulate genes to
really do something deep on the brain
yeah you've got to be much more a
biologist or neuroscientist whatever
term you want to use our cognitive you
know too much focus will make you very
narrow and boring I think that I don't
even did you sit from Jim's answer that
is always true yeah I think Sidney
alluded to this all of us alluded to
this earlier and that is we've emerged
from 50 years of understanding the
chemical nature of genes and and in
other systems it's been possible to go
from genotype to phenotype in a
relatively clear way it's not hard to
equate a change in the growth hormone
gene with short stature but the nervous
system in the nervous system moving from
genotype to phenotype has been an
elusive problem that is we can't
immediately move from a change in a gene
to a cognitive or a behavioral defect
and that's because genotype and
phenotype are separated by neural
network and it's this neural network
both anatomically and functionally that
we need to understand in order to
understand the consequence
of an alteration in a neuropeptide
receptor on social behavior or a
vasopressin receptor on promiscuity and
so it's these circuits that lie between
genotype and phenotype
just to elaborate on that point not only
is the circuit complicated but the
individual nerve cell is complicated so
an individual nerve cell makes not one
but a thousand different synaptic
connections with different target cells
many of those synaptic connections can
be regulated independently and many of
the synaptic connections have their own
machinery for local protein synthesis so
that can be activated or shadow off so
the possibilities within a given neuron
alone are much larger than one would
have thought 20 or 30 years ago and I
will you put that into a neural circuit
and you'll see what the problem is in
moving from a gene to a phenotype
without having the analysis of what goes
on what is needed is and this is what
Jim has been saying you need good cell
biology in addition to molecular biology
you need the neuroanatomy and you need
good behavior and you need appropriate
systems in which these things can be put
together probably no single system
except if we can get a reductionist
approach to people without interfering
with their lives in which this can be
tackled satisfactorily dr. Tronick on so
I just want to balance the what we are
discussing here because you know
question is where the glass is half-full
or half-empty and right now we people
have emphasized a difficulty challenge
or connecting genotype with a phenotype
in incan comes to the nervous system but
the other side is that in fact if you do
the classical genetics you know just a
mutated gene for the entire body entire
period of a life of the animal of course
it's become more difficult to interpret
behavioral deficit but if you so there
is therefore we struggle to try to
restrict genetic mutation
to a specific type of cells a specific
part of the brain and sometimes even
specific period of animals right and
then interpretation become a little bit
easier so I don't want the students to
go away and say oh this is impossible to
do any genetics in the nervous system
that is not exactly true it is a
difficult thing to do but but but it's
not as bad as you know right like a
classic genetics and try to understand
the function of gene and the behavior
dr. Brenner I'll just say one comment
about that which is that of course it's
only the fact that the gene function is
allocated to that set of cells inside
the organism that allows you to change
it in that set of cells and that is
something which I think we still need to
uncover which I call the instantiation
problem there's no such thing as a gene
but I'll leave that for another
Institute opening just let me add one
comment which I think will illuminate
this discussion I was Austin in fact if
my memories correct it was at MIT in a
lecture I gave a long time ago student
came up to me and he said dr. Britney
said what is the breakthrough in the
nervous system and I said you're almost
a hundred years too late it's called the
neuron hypothesis and that is it is that
we've got the way to think about it it
is cells cells have functions they are
connected it is the network the key
thing is of course it's harder to think
about a network then it is to think
about a double helical molecule but the
network is going to be the foundation of
why we've got to think well I can't
resist listening to being reminded of a
sociological fact that some people in
the audience may not know about and that
is 50 years these what what you are
hearing about is the enormous problems
we confront and studying the nervous
system and I think we will grant that
that's true but you may not be aware of
is the shift in scientific manpower now
in the 1950s if you were to God into
let's say 1961 you would have gone at
the Jim Watson's office and told him you
wanted to study the brain he would have
said probably quite correctly this is
premature and he was encouraging his
best students to tackle other problems
neurobiology was a small relatively
isolated community that had very few
experienced people this has changed
dramatically everyone sitting here now
is in neurobiologist I mean Jim Watson
is the neurobiologist the most gifted
people in the biological sciences are
likely to go into neurobiology the whole
nature the workforce has changed so it's
very difficult to predict where we will
be 10 or 20 years from now if you look
that granted it was a much easier
problem as to what happened in molecular
biology in the first 50 years it was
spectacular and there is no reason to
believe although it's not going to be
the pace is not going to be comparable
that we will not make great
breakthroughs in understanding neural
circuitry and as everyone here agrees
that that is the intervening step
between genes and behavior and I think
they would be principles that emerge
means Sidney's emphasis on the nerve
doctrine is absolutely right if we begin
to analyze locomotor patterns for
example and see that there are general
anatomical and functional principles in
all locomotor patterns which are very
likely to be we will begin to have some
rules if we understand perceptual
processing and see what goes on how does
information from different sources come
together and most importantly why is it
when groups are cells fired that I
experience
something issue we have not put
patterson will certainly address I mean
the ghosts in the machine is we're the
ghost in the machine
somehow activity gives rise to conscious
filing well that raises the whole issue
of wouldn't get around to this after
lunch but while I have you all here on
the stage because they're not gonna be
here after lunch to be quizzed when we
talked with people about consciousness
how does this get you closer to
consciousness I mean can your
dissections and your you know
deconstruction of the brain bring us
closer to consciousness I mean you could
really s and we should ignore the
problem it should be think it's going to
vanish or surprise it'll never be solved
it'll disappear that's my prediction
I think it's wait after a problem that
disappeared which Jim once refused to
let me talk about at a meeting
it was embryological determination and
its determination different from
differentiation at the same there were
endless discussions what was it what
they they'd have a specific flavor of
its own where's the problem there it's
gone it's vanished
that's what happens to math a lot of
scientific problem they never solved and
thirty years later people will look back
and say why were they worried about this
well what stupid people have in their
minds to worry about consciousness so I
believe it's not worthwhile working on
because it's gonna be it's gonna
disappear and what's gonna take its
place
yeah it's the machine machine it's the
machine in me not the ghost in the
machine it's the machine in me which I
was simply going to say I think that's a
very higher-order problem and we were to
see how far we get with just a
run-of-the-mill newer machinery before
we do that there may be something very
important left but I think we are likely
to make more progress don't get me wrong
I think people like the two of you
should continue to think about
consciousness but I think the majority
of people want to work on lower-level
problems
because that's going to give us insight
and how neural circuit relates the
behavior and what remains will put us in
a position to tackle these higher-order
problems
the brain west bring the microphone to
talk the Churchill thing I don't want to
steal my own fire here but but but I
essentially agree with with what Sydney
says and also with what Eric says I
think that the problem of consciousness
once we understand the fundamentals of
nervous system function of how neurons
code information of what the heck
attention is and how motor control is
organized the problem of consciousness
will essentially fall out of all that
and it's not going to be a separate
problem that we need to solve by by a
different sort of technique sort of like
string theory is today I'm such a
different topic yes sir
dr. Kendall you mentioned you mentioned
that many more researchers are now going
into neurobiology I'd be very interested
to hear why each of you went into
neurobiology either initially or after
starting in a different area of science
thank you I weren't at the neurobiology
I'm Viennese and every Viennese Jewish
boy has to go this acid so I went to
medical school to become a psychoanalyst
and had no interest in fundamental
biology whatsoever and that took an
elective period because I thought even a
psychoanalyst should know something
about the brain and that was so
exhilarating that it redirected my
career and as I got into it I began to
realize that the problems that initially
attracted me we're not tractable and I
recommend to all psychoanalysts that
they give it up and they go into
neurobiology anyone else oh sure I will
who asked that question because people
know more my work more in immunology
than the neurobiology so
depict my answer it's different
depending on who asked the true answer
is true answer is that I felt the
immunology not exciting enough anymore
and of course when I say that
immunologist will get very angry at me
and I don't think there are many
immunologist here except my friend
Antonio so it's alright but another
reason it's because I made too many
enemies in you mean ology so I wanted to
go many years ago I can't when there was
a physicist to won the Nobel Prize here
in this town and I came to this fair
city and sat down and asked him this is
like I think 1975 and I look forward to
2000 I said what do you see the future
of physics in 2000 and he said it's
thought about it for a second and he
said I think it'll become as boring as
chemistry is there anything to be
learned from other scientists
collaboratively speaking you know
working together maybe with physicists
and whatever just exchanging information
that might open up you know having
coffee in the morning or I know building
you know you were talking much about
buildings and opit calories to what
people can see each other and bump into
the halls and things like that
is there anything to be learned from
these other people are you so elitist
that that they don't want to talk to us
they don't want to talk to you that's
not true
now I think I think I still remain a
geneticist I just think the the brain is
a very interesting phenotype it's not
boring like most of the other phenotypes
we have and as Jim and I Jim will tell
you we both believe this only thing one
there's only one thing worse than bad
it's to be boring
so you think it's possible for one
machine the same machine to understand
its own machine yes why not
I'm just asked a question mean even even
Gurgel believe that even girdled believe
it I mean that sounds like philosophy
and this is just a no patters here but
absolutely avoid any discussion of logic
in your life
yes sir the basic question that we're
here to study all of us is how does the
mind emerge from the brain and this is a
question that mankind's been studying
for centuries and we were trying to
reconcile that so my question is where
are we what is the state of progress is
the neuron doctrine going to be
sufficient will we require a paradigm
shift in terms of complex systems and
emergent phenomenon if you were to try
to place in context our state of
understanding how the mind emerges from
the brain in terms of say physics where
are we with landmarks like Galileo
Newton Maxwell Einstein how far along
are we we have no idea
that's right we don't know how the brain
works yet and when we do then we won't
ask that question yeah
I think what's also important to
emphasize is that that's the excitement
of the field yeah
the reason Susumu got out of mu
knowledge e is because he thought some
of the most interesting problems have
been solved that's when people get out
of the field you're entering or
neurobiology is a field that can be
entered because most of the important
problems have not been solved I mean
that's the great challenge and this is
why I think young people find that
attractive
well you've let me pick up on that idea
because I had a similar sort of question
I had talked that I was asking dr. axle
about this before he showed these
wonderful pictures of what was the
cherries and lemons and the stimulation
of the smells in the brain but it didn't
show something that when I smell
something it evokes a memory of
something else how is that hardwired
into the cherries and lemon spots in the
blame brain or do we just not even know
that part yet we know nothing just don't
ask the question you know it's good for
a radio program that's why I stay here
and you sit over there are you his press
agent now you know questions remains on
the floor dr. axe the answer Jim gave
you the answer we know nothing but I
mean one can what we've all demonstrated
is the capability to talk about things
we don't know
so do I detect some frustration operated
about things you don't know about more
than it no we're not a thrust free I
mean we're curious I mean you may be
frustrated because you can't put
together a good program which is
understandable and DNA but talking about
this get so close to it's not
worth doing it just do it
better watch out I'll ask about your
opinions about God in a second any other
questions from yes why don't you wait
for the microphone wait wait miss for
the microphone to come over
yeah I'm Lauren Magoffin and at the risk
of having a mutation and exhibiting
greater stupidity then has been
exhibited obviously already I have a
question since our nervous system is
hardwired its prejudice hardwired in our
system he needs a very simple question
is his prejudice hardwired dr. Watson
that's the simple question right then I
understand that right well look you die
your I is wild to the right part of your
brain right if you take the if you take
the precursor the I and stick it on the
back of a frog okay it goes up the
spinal cord the fibers run up the spinal
cord and they just land up nowhere so
but that specification is not a
recognition in the eye that says get
there into the tectum that's where you
got to go what a specification is it
says recognize this molecule and keep on
going till we tell you to stop okay and
it just so happens incidentally much of
the same specificities in the spinal
cord but you know that never occurs in
nature nature doesn't have to eliminate
unknown things that is the beauty of
natural selection so we don't have to
puzzle how did the I now to do this just
just happen to be there and it's of no
account in normal development I give you
this as the example that if we try to
specify everything by a sir
number we're going to be wrong because
there are many things in our even at the
lowest level of the genome that are done
care conditions it doesn't matter
whether it's up or down but cannot works
can i sum that up by saying and tell me
if I'm wrong that's the kind of question
she's asking is a consciousness question
and you're not you folks don't study
consciousness so you couldn't answer
that kind of question now I still dunno
what what the question she's asking him
it back to a nature nurture question
she's saying is is present prejudice
hardwired into your system well it's
basically a nature nurture could be it
could be we may have been advantageous
twenty-five thousand yeah let's say I
have strong prejudice no I think you
know something they're still logical our
brain doesn't really like geological
things and so when we hear ill logic we
just say crap and that you could say
that's prejudice that I'm using the word
crap and but that's a just responses
yeah so now I think you have to conceive
of this animal that we used to be and
you have to ask yourself what were we
selected for in the environment that
disappeared thousands we have still in
herre stood that genome and our problem
is how to how to sort of confront the
products of our brain with that animal
that is still within us if I can put it
in crude but I think the sort of the
feeling that we're not that society now
is not evolving at the genetic level I
think it is and there's probably a
fairly strong selection you know or a
selection for less aggressive people
because if you're aggressive you know
very early age
either you know put away so and so
that's certainly a trend and so you
could say there's you know certainly a
selection for because our groups get
bigger and bigger for us being more
politically correct
real selections for that because society
and sort of demands it and I think that
would be you know that's sort of for
developing a no logical right you know
you you do something because you're
supposed to do it rather than you
believe you should don't but I think
we're on the whole survival because
their brain living pretty logical yeah
can I just have a crack at answering
that or you see whether this is more or
less along the lines that you were
thinking and that is that presumably
humans along with other social animals
like baboons and wolves and chimpanzees
have dispositions for sociability like
the prairie voles we have vasopressin
and oxytocin we form social groups and
part of that I think looks like we have
very strong adherents to the group and
very strong rejection of the out group
so in that sense I think that there is
an early imprinting on the types of
individuals within your in-group and so
you're more likely to feel comfortable
and appropriate with the people who
belonged to your small group whatever
whatever it happened to be your family
or your clan and then
and so on but then as Jim rightly points
out as society changes and we live not
just in these small clans then some of
the in-group out-group stuff becomes
really a problem and and and the name
that it often gets is prejudice and so
something along those lines seems to me
to be the way to explain this really
very natural but tremendously strong
feeling of connection to the clan or
family or group that that you're born
into and yes lady right back there stand
up get the mic at the risk of asking you
another consciousness question I'm
really curious about how fruitful you
think the researchers who are working
with the Dalai Lama and other meditators
people who've spent their lives trying
to develop their consciousness and
develop their understanding of
consciousness do you think that these
studies will prove to be fruitful and
open up new doors for neuroscience I'll
tell you the answer to that question it
depends on your age if your 20s to 30s
people will say hey man this is the
great thing a new insight into
everything if you 40 you'll get the
judicious reply saying we can't say
whether this is some probability it
might have an effect we don't want to
rule it out completely but when you get
to our age we just say it's a lot of
rubbish
just forget about it from a point of
view of science if it makes you feel
good I'm not gonna stop you
well that goes back to what you saying
the scientists have done their best work
by the time they're 30 years exactly I
said I see ones who have done any work
at all there was a question over here
somebody had behind alright okay hi you
spoke earlier about possibly coming back
in 20 53 and seeing what had happened in
the field and my question was more about
the practical applications of your works
and not what would happen in science and
what would be the fruit of your labors
and those that come after you but more
how would the world look different as a
result of the things we hope to learn in
the coming years dr. Caine there let me
let me spin that question a little bit
because I say everybody's mouths are
open a little you you mentioned about
all the implications art culture
whatever that they're the impacts of
this work is going to have do these
disciplines understand that themselves
the people who work there understand how
brain research or brain understating the
brain is going to affect their own
discipline by and large no I mean let me
indicate the time and so maybe too young
to realize that but when I enter the
psychiatrist many psychiatrists didn't
believe that illnesses other than the
major psychosis occurred in the brain so
you could understand if if a discipline
medically trained disciplined was so
unaware of what the brain does you can
understand how people who are art
historians or economists do not but in
every one of those fields one of the
reasons I specifically selected them
there is a significant avant-garde group
that is sensitive to it and is trying to
do that in fact Richard David Friedman a
Friedberg and I are trying to organize
something at Columbia and neurobiology
and art certainly lots of groups are
doing this this is an interesting area
and in each one of the topics that are
listed there are people within the
discipline that are trying to do that if
your cat if you're cataloging I think
also the lead
and social cataloging all the genes but
with the simplest one they come back to
it Sidney said is if we understood more
about learning and memory for example
and we had some insight they could not
only be used in experimental animals but
it could give us insights into how we
could improve you know learning for
example if neurogenesis is important we
know that exercise stimulates
neurogenesis you would encourage people
to exercise more at certain phases
particularly certain phases of their
career I'm making this up this but you
are certainly likely to get biological
insights that will lead you to altering
child-rearing patterns educational
patterns that's the hope
we're also on the other hand if you
understood that with the the Flies have
900 genes for smell we will different
genes if I understood you correctly
could you then give me that gene for a
pheromone that I don't smell now and I
could use later on that experience been
done in the worm by Cori Bargmann you
can you can change either the
sensitivity of an organism to its world
where you can change the behavioral
response of an organism by putting a
gene in a different neural this is we
need to what we need to do is to wire up
the auditory input to the visual
analyzer then we could really see one
Beethoven's dr. Watson said that we
hadn't found the double helix of the
brain I wonder where the panel would
like to comment on Dawkins notion of a
meme and if I may a second question five
Nobel laureates five great senses of
human nature or nurture
I think that answers itself that
question and why do we respond to the
first you want any Jim Jim to forget the
question only I forgot the question
Richard or can came up with the idea of
a replicator of the mind called any any
analogy between that and the missing
spiral DNA no I mean you know a meme is
you know religion or something like that
you know so to understand understand you
know how these things started and so on
it's a useful way of looking at society
but you know which is not a
neuroscientist so he worries about these
things well we've got more serious
things are serious things we have to do
now as to thank our panel thank you for
[Applause]
let me announce let me announce lunch
plans if you have a badge a lunch will
be served behind the curtains or behind
this side if you have signed up before
lunch on the internet there are box
lunches on the sixth floor upstairs
we'll see you all back here after lunch
at about 220
you